THEY ARE GOING TO AVOID THOSE
LABELS OR GETTING THE TREATMENT
THAT WILL WORK.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INSIGHT, PROFESSOR.
OBAMA'S WHITE HOUSE WAS THE
REVOLVING DOOR FOR CELEBRITIES.
REMEMBER WHEN HE HAD THE SUMMIT
WITH RAPPERS LUDACRIS.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T BECAUSE THE
LEFT WING MEDIA DIDN'T FREAK OUT
OVER IT.
JOINING US WITH REACTION, DOUBLE
STANDARD HOWIE KIRT.
HOWIE, MEDIA BUZZ, GREAT SHOW ON
THE WEEKENDS ON FOX.
THIS IS WILD.
I REMEMBER WHEN KANYE CAME AND
DID HIS POETRY SLAM AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TRUTH BE TOLD, I KIND OF LAUGHED
AT IT.
I THOUGHT THE POEM WAS REALLY
BAD HE DID ON STAGE.
OBAMA WAS REALLY AT EASE WITH
CELEBRITIES.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY LOVED HIM.
NO ONE CARED.
>> OBAMA'S CELEBRITIES AND
RAPPERS THEY HAD THE APPROVED
IDEOLOGY.
THE MEDIA KIND OF CELEBRATED IT.
LOOK, WHAT KANYE DID IN THE OVAL
OFFICE, IT IS FINE FOR CRITICS
TO SAY, IT WAS WEIRD, STRANGE,
BIZARRE.
EVEN DONALD TRUMP SEEMED KIND OF
SPEECHLESS FOR A MOMENT BUT THE
BRUTAL NATURE OF THE CRITICISM
IS DRIVEN BY IDEOLOGY.
WHEN KANYE WEST WAS TALKING
ABOUT, GEORGE BUSH DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE, A LOT OF THE
LIBERALS SAID HE IS A COOL DUDE.
BECAUSE HE IS WEARING THE RED
HAT AND EMBRACING DONALD TRUMP,
HE MUST BELOW GO.
>> WHAT ARE THE CHANCES NEXT
WEEK HE WILL BE WEARING A CORY
BOOKER HAT?
IS THERE ANY CHANCE?
>> JACQUE SPIRE, CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM CALIFORNIA SAID THIS ABOUT
KANYE AND HIS MENTAL HEALTH.
>> IT WAS A COMBINATION OF
STREAM OF CONSCIOUSNESS.
I FELT LIKE I WAS SITTING IN ON
A PSYCHIATRIC VISIT AND A
COMMERCIAL FOR DONALD TRUMP.
IT WASN'T NEWSWORTHY CERTAINLY
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD MAYBE CURTAIL
THESE KINDS OF ENGAGEMENTS.
36% APPROVAL FROM RASMUSSEN
AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE MORE O
WORRIED ABOUT KANYE'S EFFECT ON
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS THAN HIS
MENTAL HEALTH.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE
CONGRESSWOMAN, IT SEEMS LIKE THE
HARSHEST CRITICISM IS COMING
FROM OTHER AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
DON LEMON BRINGING HIS LATE
MOTHER INTO IT.
CNN SAID HE WAS A TOKEN NEGRO.
I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT PHRASE IN
DECADES.
IT IS ROOTED IN THE NOTION THAT
BLACK PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE DONALD TRUMP, THEY
CAN'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY MISS
INFORMED AND THEY HAVE SERIOUS
ISSUES AND ALL THAT.
THEY NO LONGER HAVE A MONOPOLY.
THE PILING ON ABOUT KANYE WEST,
PROBABLY DOESN'T KNOW THAT MUCH
MORE ABOUT POLITICS.
>> MORE SO THAN WHO, MATT DAMON?
>> HE WAS THERE TO TALK ABOUT A
SERIOUS ISSUE.